[Music]
today's question comes from eric in iowa
eric writes my girlfriend and i are 26
and have been dating for about a year
and we both have similar amounts of
student loan debt i really want to pay
off my student loans within the next
couple years because all of the stress
that it causes me my girlfriend wants to
live it up while we're young and ignore
her student loans for as long as
possible i feel guilty when we spend
money on entertainment and vacations
because it's postponing our journey to
becoming debt free whenever i bring up
my concerns about our spending habits
she becomes dismissive
i'm worried that she views paying off
student loans as an insurmountable
challenge how can i convince her to take
action with me if i can't is this a lost
cause
dave this doesn't sound like it's about
debt it sounds like
about somebody who loves somebody
and
he keeps trying to say hey this is an
important value for me and the
continuation of our relationship and the
person he loves is saying it's not for
me
and we're going to move on
and that's hard
that's real hard
yeah
it is it's going to be a heartbreak here
yep but either sooner or later yeah
um or
she's going to suddenly grow up one of
the two because she's being a child
um so eric here's the problem the number
one cause of divorce in north america
today the number one thing people fight
about
is money
and money problems and so when you are
not in agreement not in alignment
on the number one problem in marriage
that's like a flare going off warning
warning warning warning warning you're
about to screw up that's what that's
saying right i mean if like the number
one way that your car blows up is when
this one light comes on and it comes on
and it comes off you pull over quick
you're about to blow your freaking car
up i mean
you're not the exception to this okay so
that's what's going on uh that's where
you are and so
regardless of her
motivation her reason her lack of hope
her
or she's just a princess or whatever it
is she's not in alignment with you
and you guys are you're using a lot of
wee language with a girlfriend yeah
okay there's not a we
when it's a girlfriend there's a we date
but we don't have a budget because
there's not a we you're not married
uh when you're married it's a we yeah
but until you're married it's not a we
and even when it's a fiance it's not a
we it's a future we but it's not a week
and right now this is just a girlfriend
you said that three times by the way
yeah and i had a buddy who talked to me
he gave me this phrase when it came to
um eating right and um
exercising
and he said man being a hundred pounds
overweight is really hard it's
exhausting your knees hurt your back or
it's hard and exercising and losing
hundred pounds is really hard so the
goal here isn't avoidance of hard the
goal is what heart are you going to
choose
and by not choosing a heart you
automatically choose
something hard that's right so it's not
avoiding the the discomfort so i'll use
that same phrase with with eric
being with somebody that you love who
constantly dismisses a value you have
you constantly feel guilt even when
you're having fun and doing joyful
things together is gonna be really hard
it's a hard way to live
and having a conversation with somebody
you love saying i'm scared about debt
i don't want to enter into a marriage
with you and still have this stuff can
we start now is going to be a hard
conversation pick your heart either way
moving forward you're going to have a
hard conversation it's better to have it
on the front end and be honest and be
direct and then move on well i'm i'm
afraid we'll break up well you're going
to break up you're going to break up
it's just a matter of whether it's after
you're married yeah and 200 000 in debt
or whether before you're married and you
don't have her debt yeah
i tell addicts you're gonna get a group
you get to choose one or the court will
order you into one you get to pick
you're gonna break up yes does a lawyer
gonna take your money or not right have
the conversation
how much pain and children are gonna be
involved that's the only question so um
yeah this is not the thing so but she
could say okay you know it's a big deal
to you and maybe i need to need to look
at this and let's turn around on eric
don't come to her and say hey we got to
get this debt paid off we got come to
her and say there's not a we by the way
i'm scared i'm paying off my debt and
for us to go forward we've got to be in
alignment you can't you can't like you
know
uh i'm not going to go on vacations that
is not a reason to break up no
not being in alignment on money and how
it's going to be handled and children
and how they're going to be handled and
if we're going to have them and in-laws
that are crazy and how we're going to
deal with them and religion these are
the four things the four the four
horsemen that will destroy your marriage
um in-laws
extended family how we're going to deal
with the crazy extended family because
there's one there's one in every pile
i'm just telling you and um
the the uh how are we going to have kids
and are the inmates going to run the
asylum or are the kids going to behave
um all this kind of stuff uh
money how are we gonna handle that are
we gonna save we're gonna live within
our means are we gonna stay out of debt
um are we just gonna go yolo thank god
it's friday i'm a child
and which is what she's doing
and um oh
and you know uh we're gonna have you
know
i i believe in god and i think you're an
idiot for believing in god these are our
two religions this is not gonna work
either so uh it's very very difficult
those are the fourth
most likely things uh value system
things heavy discussions that enter into
the uh uh
poison in the dna of a marriage yeah and
i think beneath that is
how are we gonna
if you tell me one of your values and i
don't believe it's a value of mine how
am i going to respond am i going to
ignore am i going to blow you off am i
going to say i'll hold your hand and go
deeper down that let's go talk to
somebody let's get some more information
let's go meet with experts
how are we going to approach those
crossroads when we have them um is also
i think it's important man and this just
complete dismissal yeah it's danger will
robinson get out we're going to have
toxic conflict we're going to have
healthy conflict or we're going to have
no conflict which is also toxic conflict
that's right yeah no no yes except that
one's just more insidious because it
poisons everyone around you when a
spouse and a husband are yelling at each
other
everybody knows stay away when they're
just burning the that no conflict and
feel it in the air
everyone's shoulders are tight
just walk in the room and everybody's on
eggshells so all that to say eric um
yeah if you were my son
uh i would say hey
time to have a what they call it dtr dtr
i learned
the relationship back when my kids were
teenagers 25 years ago
um yeah it's time to define the
relationship and are we going are we
just dating in which case you get to do
whatever stupid butt stuff you want to
do with your personal life we're just
dating um but if we're moving towards
something more serious than dating which
is the way this is worded um a
requirement of that is a you're not
gonna be dismissive of things that are
important to me this matters to me i'm
scared about this and b i'm not gonna be
dismissive of you when things are
important to you
and see we've got to be in alignment on
the big things
the little things we can work around but
the big things can't work around those
can't
work around those
luckily
they got me and you and we're perfect
husbands and um
and our advice is always right 100
percent
eric this is and it was free these are
four
tripped and fallen a few times yeah
we've got
i've answered this question about
somebody's been married 10 years
and i've answered this question from
before they ever get married it's a lot
easier before you get married